Samantha starts off this hour and
Detroit Michigan
hi Samantha how are you I'm good Dave
I just have a quick question for you we
went through SPU back in July and in SPU
we had to have our car repossessed so we
were let me stop a second that sounded
like FP you caused your car to be
repossessed that's not true wait a
minute stop no no we
while you were in FP you you were so far
behind they took your car correct okay I
just like stating it that way better
okay people I'm not going to be you they
repossess your car okay all right anyway
so I'm sorry that's a hard thing to go
through isn't it yes it is and we went
without a car from July until September
and we bought a car in September two
weeks later that had gasket blew and we
built our emergency fund up to a
thousand we weren't sure if it was the
head gasket if there's a thermostat so
we through our emergency fund into
fixing something that it wasn't and come
to find out it's a head gasket some
wondering do I rebuild my emergency fund
or do I fix this car so the head gasket
is still blown correct so is the car
parked or is it limping
it was limping and I just parked it last
week because I'm like I'm not going to
do any more damage to it okay and so we
don't have a car right now no okay and
what does it take to fix this car I've
taken it to four different places and
they said it's about $1,600 to fix it
okay and what is the car worth probably
like only eight or nine on Bluebook
thousand no hundred okay well here's a
clue we don't spend sixteen hundred
dollars on an $800 car so what you do is
you sell the car for Salvage as is and
you take the 1,600 that you were going
to spend you put that with whatever you
get for salvage and you buy the next car
okay yeah I would not repair an $800 car
with a $1600 repair because after you do
the $69 repair you know what the car is
worth eight hundred and fifty dollars
right so you
you know the 1600 just kind of thrown
out the window you'd be better off to be
driving a $1600 car which is twice as
good a car as you have by the way right
so rebuild the fund well save up money
like crazy let's get you a car as soon
as possible and by selling this car or
drive it into the dirt if you want to
now that we're going to sell it for
Salvage okay I mean I mean I I'm
guessing that it's not going to bring
much for five for five hundred bucks or
something right right and the junkyard
said it was only worth like a hundred
bucks for them to come get it down well
that's not even as good as I thought
okay well maybe maybe maybe you don't
drive it in the dirt maybe you go ahead
and sell it for 500 now on Craigslist or
something and tell people that the head
gasket is blown but some shade-tree
mechanic may like to fix that and makes
me see that as a bargain right so
because not it's mostly labor I mean
you'll have to have the heads machine
usually depending on what kind of engine
it is and so forth but the vast majority
of the 1,600 is labor and someone that
knows how to do the repair might pay you
500 bucks for the car so let's try to
sell it before it does blow then and and
then start piling up cash and yeah
before I build my emergency fund I am
buying a car this is a full-on emergency
to have no transportation and again you
know you're looking for another garage
sale car that one just didn't work very
well but I run into people all the time
they buy one in two thousand dollar cars
that have a lot of life left in them and
have them drive them for two or three
years many times but this is kind of a
throwaway level of car it's a level of
car you throw away when it breaks to
this level when it has when it has a
repair of this size hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]